okay brows it's your boy psychobabble
let's just see how this guy's apparently
this games like really good actually
and it is like Diablo apparently so I
guess we'll just look don't take my
before report and I like just yeah I
gotta say this kid
Charlie yell say
hold down
I would at this guy he's just like doing
it's best that I just [ __ ] do it I
guess
oh my game
you start my game
no friends if I get a traveling to squid
coast don't mind if I tell you no don't
behind if I tell the village is burning
no doubt this is the work of the evil
arch illa jure and his minions they
sweep across the land like a ravenous
scourge subjugating or destroying all in
their path this is a time for heroes
like yourself
make haste the villagers have need of
you
alright go to the village I've checked
like that
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
you are too late to rescue the villagers
but don't fret they're still out there
somewhere waiting for a hero to find
them squid Coe sweetie rebus
good my projectiles are like dead
thank you